it has to be a collective definition of
a good life the definition of a good
life to me is a society a world where
the majority of the people have the
fundamental basic rights freedom of
association freedom of assembly freedom
from poverty a world where the right
straight job is an economic right a
world where the lives of all human
beings is meaningful doesn't it to be
luxury it's meaningful people are
content people have the basic needs and
we can't we're not talking here about
equal outcomes I talk about eco
opportunities if we can guarantee equal
opportunities to citizens of the globe
that would be a measure of success